talk to me about bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies how does that fit into
all this
yeah great question so uh uh yo to slide
104 um so we've back tested everything
that ticks in macro if we can invest in
it or or if there's something some way
to get exposure to it we back tested it
within the context of those grids and
right now we're actually long bitcoin
and ethereum in our model portfolio
construction as a function of sort of
being in this in this kind of hybrid
what we call grid zero environment
whereby you know each of the the four
grid regimes is reasonably probable over
the next um over the next few months and
so understanding that bitcoin if you
look at that back test it sees it has
137 percent annualized monthly return
whenever we're in inflation that's
stagflation and so that's one of the
exposures we've actually allocated to in
the model portfolio construction to take
advantage of the fact that hey you know
that the economy may actually tip into
stagflation here in q4 and if we're if
we're wrong on our views on reflation
and it actually is stagflation you're
going to have some exposure to to to
that downside risk with respect to uh
asset markets and so bitcoin ethereum
two of the best places you can be right
now as it relates to pricing and
stagflation mac gas uranium uh those are
other features in the portfolio
construction as well uh we're not all
fully built uh tilted into stagflation
but we certainly think crypto plays a
very important role in terms of
protecting investor portfolios to the
upside of inflation and also to the
downside and growth over the next few
months
talk about when you're looking at it in
terms of that
protection to a portfolio uh in both of
those scenarios what is the allocation
size that you're seeing is this like
half a percent one percent type stuff is
it five ten percent bigger somewhere in
between
yeah so i've i've spent
many years consulting uh institutional
investors on on portfolio construction
and really position sizing that's kind
of like the final frontier of investing
there's no real
right way to do it there's wrong ways to
do it for sure i think licking your
finger in the air is probably the worst
way to do it um but the reality is i
mean i've tried ever you know being
various optims i've tried it all and the
reality is nothing works
nothing works ex-ante it always works x
post and so i've actually just gone i've
gone straight with just uh equal
weighted position sizes but more
importantly controlling your uh
allocation to the themes
if you do have the slide deck if you
have the slide that go to slide 23
you'll see sort of how we're balanced
across the four different regimes and
also have a decent cast magician in the
context of expecting a little bit more
volatility in asset markets over the
next kind of two to three weeks i think
earnings season could potentially be
negative uh we got a bunch of economic
data this week that could be negative
ppi or cpi tomorrow ppi thursday retail
sales friday consumer confidence friday
but it really as you can see here it's
really just about allocating to each of
the regimes and right now we're in this
hybrid grid zero portfolio construction
where we're saying hey each of the four
regimes is reasonably probable in terms
of realizing that economically here in
q4 both in the us economy and also
abroad and so we don't want to be tilted
too far into any one regime if you if we
had this conversation in november of
last year that entire freaking circle
would be lime green it's like this is
going to be the most historic inflation
trade you've ever seen in your life i
was on several programs like this saying
that screaming at the top of my lungs
saying look bitcoin's probably going to
a hundred thousand by the spring now we
only got to 60-some thousand but i
certainly think that's probably going
100 000 by the end of this year um and
that's and you can you can write me down
on that i like i like time stamps but
the reality is the the size of each of
those pie slices in the portfolio
construction varies with respect to uh
what's the actual probability of
realizing that regime and so right now
the probabilities are pretty balanced so
we're pretty balanced but the next you
know the next time next time you get me
on the program it may be all dark blue
or maybe all dark green who knows
when you think about bitcoin
specifically you said 100k by the end of
the year is that uh a floor that you
think will cross over or do you think
that's more of like a market top uh and
that's how that's like the highest you
could see it going
no no i i mean this thing's i mean pick
your duration it's going to keep going
up right like we know the supply the fi
is being halved at various intervals so
it's really just about not being the guy
or gal who buys the top of the chart and
has to huddle that for like three years
that's that's what you got to avoid in
bitcoin right like that you know and so
um you know i've been following the
stock to flow analysis just like
everybody else and i don't pretend i
don't purport to be an expert in bitcoin
i purport to be an expert in
understanding how the asset actually
trades with respect to its own
volatility and covariance and return
characteristics as a function of the
economic cycle what's happening in the
economy that's what i'm an expert on and
in terms of using that expertise um i
would say hey look as long as we're in
this period where we could either be in
goldilocks reflation or stagflation or
sorry not you can be in but rather each
of those has a reasonably probable
probability for uh being realized that
you're going to have positive price
momentum and bitcoin and that's exactly
what we're seeing that's exactly what
we'd expect to continue to see through
year end ultimately the the the sales
signal on bitcoin it'll be when this
sort of net liquidity dynamic really
starts to inflect or at least afford
outlook for it to start to reflect lower
because what we've seen historically
going back to 2017 heading into 2018 was
that bitcoin you know ahead of these big
market moves tends to be a leading
indicator um obviously bitcoin peaked um
you know in in q1 of last year prior to
the stock market you know so there there
is some leading characteristics with
respect to bitcoin and partially because
it's more of a pure market right again
i'm not i'm you know it's certainly not
a bitcoin cheerleader i think it's just
i think of bitcoin the same way i think
of all the other uh they're like kids in
the portfolio construction you know one
kid sometimes or is acting up someone
said one kid's out there winning awards
sometimes and it's witches reality is is
understanding portfolio construction and
where each of these these children fit
in that context is really the name of
the game
in my opinion